rock climbing is getting a lot more
popular there's indoor gyms like this
one opening all around the country and
in 2020 for the first time it will be an
official sport at the Olympics made up
of three events the first is lead
climbing
that's scaling a tall wall using a rope
that you use to anchor yourself along a
route that changes from competition to
competition
the second is bouldering no rope this
time because it's closer to the ground
but the problems are physically and
mentally a lot more demanding like lead
climbing the routes change free
competition to competition and the third
is speed climbing which is exactly what
it sounds like
climb a 15 meter wall as fast as you
possibly can here's the twist
unlike lead climbing and bouldering the
route stays the same every single time
the holds like this one are standardized
and they're in the exact same position
in the exact same place along the route
whether you're climbing today a year
from now in the US or abroad the fastest
time ever recorded on a speed wall is
five point four eight seconds look at
that time go down new world record
today we're gonna look at like climbing
a speed wall in five seconds flat is
almost impossible
[Music]
to find out what it takes I climbed with
one of the fastest American speed
climbers okay talk big wall speed
planning with Alex Honnold yes many
Jewish becoming big walls you know think
about your lactate threshold you just do
it over and over in this you know it
improves and the physics of flying up
the equivalent of a four-story building
with a biomechanist like it's big father
most women's and selfless issue is very
very important
climbing fast in and of itself isn't
exactly new people have been racing each
other up walls since at least the 1940s
but the standardized route that will see
for speed climbing in the Olympics has
only been around for a few years the
very fastest climber Iranian Raisa a
leap or set the world record at five
point four eight seconds in 2017 but not
even a decade earlier the record was in
the mid six second range today that's
how long it takes this 16 year old
champion sprint up the wall so we're
here today at Earth Trek's gym in
Englewood Colorado we're gonna do some
speed climbing and with us today to help
us out is two-time national champion
Jordan Fishman you have a couple Records
and speed climbing right yeah alright
he's very fast at it and also with us is
Alex Honnold
he is a speed climber of a different
sort he works on bigger walls and you've
actually never climbed this either right
I've never climbed the speed wall off of
them this is gonna be great Larry
alright I haven't either I'm super
nervous let's try this I went first so
exciting let's just say that I did not
set any records he's off like a rocket
it took me more than a minute to get up
the wall okay one minute 15 seconds ha
all right
Alex's turn then it was Honnold stern
not surprisingly he was much faster he
made it to the top in just under 30
seconds only nine seconds
if y'all winded and kind of shaky so the
progression was 75 seconds twenty nine
and a half seconds
let's see you Jordan he's even with a
couple of missteps he scrambled up the
wall in eight and a half seconds
just to walk in the park and though it's
pretty classic that with mistakes and as
a warm-up it's still either half seconds
just for comparison here is a shot of
each of us on our first climbs as you
can see I'm picking my way slowly up the
wall figuring out the hold as I go to be
totally honest my main focus here is on
not falling so I'm being very deliberate
with my movements and as a result
cleaning very slowly now take a look at
Hana here in the middle like me he's
climbing this route for the very first
time so he's figuring it out as he goes
but he's still much faster in the time
it takes me to reach the top puddles
could have climbed this route two and a
half times and a lot of that has to do
with his strength and confidence but
also pay attention to his footwork to
move fast he's using not just the holds
on the wall but the wall itself climbers
call this smearing and on the speed wall
it spares them from looking down to find
footholds saving them valuable time and
then there's Fishman on the far right he
knows this route by heart so he's
relying on explosive strength and muscle
memory to blast himself up the wall like
Honnold he's also smearing his feet he's
moving so fast that he stumbles a couple
of times but even with those missteps he
still soars up this wall in the time it
takes me to climb it once
Fishman could have climbed it and tagged
the buzzer at the top nearly nine times
I was obviously the slowest it took me
75 seconds to complete the run Alex was
a lot faster than I was he took just
under 30 seconds to complete it and
Jordan you took about let's see that's
eight and a half seconds to run through
that as a warm-up run few slips and
you're alright but that's a huge
difference and I feel like a lot of it
boils down to the style with which we
were climbing it like I was being a lot
more delicate about it Alex you were
smearing a lot so you were just putting
your foot directly on the wall I was
trying to but obviously there was a lot
of room for improvement so why were you
doing that we just so that I didn't have
to think about the footholds as much
basically so I could focus on just
making big moves you turn hand holds
alright and then you just blaze through
it eight and a half seconds so what what
how do you how do you trim off twenty
seconds well partly
he didn't have to think about anything
because he knows exactly what to do so
his body is just executing without
thinking about it yeah that's the other
thing this is the first time I've ever
done it this is the first time alex has
ever done it so there's nothing for us
that he would improve that's the spirit
yeah how did you get faster for one
knowing the route helped and knowing the
holds like where you have to grab them
and when you have to grab them because I
just like just thinking takes time off
so by doing that you can get faster and
that also helps with your feet because
you know where to place them so you
don't think about that either as you
might expect the start is crucial if you
have a bad start you can kind of ruin
your run because as you push off you
have to carry that momentum all the way
up through the entire out so if you
don't get as fast and start typically
your run isn't as fast even if you can
catch up speed wood fishermen and many
other elite speed climbers do is bypass
an entire hole if you want to go foot
and hand at the same time so you kind of
you get back you generate as you pull
you push off of this foot cut and then
ya catch like this yeah and then you
kind of start to barn-door but you want
to carry the barn door through and then
fly over and then fly upward exactly the
move is now called the Reza for the
iranian climber who has used it to slash
the record up to 15 meter wall to five
point four eight seconds like it's just
shaved so much time off and it it almost
makes you flow better through the next
like three or four moves cuz you like
better set up there already but the reza
is not easy i struggled so did Hahnel
but even without a reza start can we get
faster we each went again to find out I
shade 40 seconds off my first time
running it in 35 seconds Donald took
five seconds off doing a twenty four
point five second run
and Fishman Fishman crushed it
six point six two seconds and your
record is six point three eight yep
right so that's crazy and that's like
you know you were saying on just on any
given day yeah I feel like your record
could be a lot lower yes any random
morning we're not even that warm that we
have yeah yeah we I mean we just showed
up and did a little climate most most
days I'll get average anywhere from like
six five to six eight or nine but it all
just depends on the run and the day
you're having so would you consider that
a good run
yeah like surprisingly good yeah for
like some I warm to and how many of
those do you have in you on a given day
ah anywhere sometimes we'll do two runs
a day sometimes we'll do eight or nine
but yeah yeah but it doesn't take money
in your cooks right yeah yeah it's funny
to think that doing six seconds of
musician six times and you're done for
the day man I worked out for 45 seconds
- yeah totally anaerobic right and what
you're doing is much more aerobic yeah
what I'm doing is a completely aerobic
it's basically what you're doing is
basically a marathon and you're doing a
sprint yeah many people know Honnold as
the subject of free solo the 2018
documentary about his Robles ascent of
El Capitan in Yosemite National Park but
he's also set a number of speed records
in the park including the 3,000 foot
nose route of El Cap which he scaled
with Tommy Caldwell in record time in
2018 this footage of the record climb
comes from an upcoming film from real
rock it takes most people multiple days
to complete that climb but Honnold and
Caldwell did it in just under two hours
speed climbing outdoors is more about
precision and smoothness than it is
about being sloppy and and fast which is
part of the reason why I like people
aren't climbing the nose in minutes
right yeah yeah that's the reason why it
takes a couple hours to climb you know
pretty much the most big walls outside
yeah could you apply indoor speed
climbing tactics to big walls not
exactly in thinking about the speed
while indoors is that there's absolutely
no risk so you can you can be as free as
you want like you
take risks but outdoors if you take risk
you're gonna you know you could
potentially die on something and the
climbing style is completely different I
went to Diablo Rock Gym in Concord
California to talk with Hans fluorine is
tough so I usually will go off to the
footholds on the sides
Florine literally wrote the book on
speed climbing big walls and has owned
the knows record numerous times he was a
speed climbing star in the 90s but he's
still really fast this is the first ever
World Championship speed climbing cup
team teaching yet fully drinkable he's
in his 50s and last year broke both his
legs and both his ankles falling on El
Cap he still beat me up the wall twice
then he showed me what it's like to
climb on El Cap outside my hand I sort
of we went to the gyms crack wall which
simulates the Fisher granite that you
find on much of the nose route and
requires a completely different style of
climbing remember just rotate your hand
or your wrist and find where it's most
comfortable or least painful it only
took me you know three four minutes
right but then again that's only 30 feet
so yeah 3,000 feet on El Cap you do 99
more laps and this would be a really
long show but that would be doing the
nose in a day at the gym right and so
and then there's the weight of all the
safety equipment you have to tape you've
got this extra added weight this is
probably you know 11 12 13 pounds and
that's about what you'd carry if you
were just gonna climb the nose of El Cap
in a single day still experienced
climbers like fluorine and Honnold think
the time for a classic route like the
nose could still be brought down and we
thought it was kind of like the marathon
that it would you know get close to two
hours but then it turns out it's
actually wasn't that hard to break two
hours I it's not like the marathon it'll
probably go down to 120 I think that if
you applied the climbing pace that's
used on on an indoor climbing wall to El
Cap I mean yeah you could do in half an
hour but it's just hard to imagine
climbing that quickly while still
placing protection and clipping your
rope and managing all the other systems
but the speed wall is pure climbing
could it get any faster the start is
clearly key but there's more elements to
the climb than that so I called up
French
researcher Pierre la grenouille although
I was the first champion speak Chinese
champion in France in 1989 and now I'm
working biomechanics in climbing laguna
has studied speed finding data and found
that the fastest athletes optimize their
reach the top
it is like the fable of the hair on the
total so her goal was very fast and
spends his time sleeping and walking or
once apart so it will cover a lot of way
and we take a lot longer than torture
that never stops and moves in a straight
line and the speed climbing is similar
if the path of the body mass Center is
very very long the time at the end will
also be very high take a look at this
graph based on like runners research the
blue line is the path to the climber
center-of-mass takes from the bottom of
the climb to the top the red lines are
the furthest that a climber center of
mass moves left or right the straighter
the blue line and the narrower the red
ones the faster an athlete can climb
that is exactly what Reza did when he
eliminated that fourth handhold what's
the word to us created the idea of the
would settle was to position the
positron back to the left in the
starting position likes us and that's
the first for hunt part of the word a
position to the left of the Waseem name
here's video of Reza in 2013 as you can
see he makes this big arc going to the
fourth hold here he is again in 2017
this time pulling off his signature move
it straightens the curve and makes him
considerably faster to make a website
it's necessary to arrive on the third
handhold with a very high speed but not
how people use the Reza it requires a
lot of strength and coordination and
there's another variable as well that's
the texture of the wall itself so the
holds might not change their position
might not change but some walls are
super rough which is good and others are
super slick which can make it really
hard to get your shoe on it and get
yourself that push you need to move up
the wall a very important point for the
foot we're there for
to summarize the surface of the worlds
to allow climbers to invent new
strategies that will allow to climb up
faster and faster
Fishman coached Donald and I through
some other tricks of the wall and in the
end we both got a lot faster I notched a
run in just under 30 seconds and Hahnel
pulled one off in 20 2.3 seconds
neither of us ever completed the Reza
and I struggled with the Dinos big leaps
from one hole to another libanon thinks
that one of the ways for climbers that
go faster is to eliminate as many dinos
as possible from their clients let's
face it those big dynamic moves might
look awesome in bouldering but that
doesn't make them fast on the speed walk
here's a chart of climbing velocity up
the speed walk it's constantly rising
and falling as the athletes progress up
the climb but the greatest variations
come from dinos
it's things that the diamond is a very
very technical movement that doesn't
help to gain time but which can lose
alone find a way to maintain contact
through that same sequence of holds and
climbers could go even faster legged
owner thinks that with other
optimizations the ultimate time in this
already fast sport could drop by a lot
fifty seconds so about a whole second
faster yeah yeah very disciplined that
will greatly greatly evolved with
integration into the NB games problem so
consequently very large scientific and
financial resources will be invested on
improving performance those resources
could go to studying ways to maximize
climbing power although after seeing
Fishman's training routine it's hard to
imagine this sport getting any burlier
than it already is absurd but with more
athletes and coaches working on the wall
more variations like the Reza might be
found smooth and speed up the path that
will be and my opinions our greatest
challenge for coaches and biomechanics
but until all of those things happen
just keep in mind that what elite
climbers are doing on the speed wall and
on big walls like El Cap is already
almost impossible
[Music]